foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm I'm
Piers Morgan Live From New York
uncensored tonight
Scandal rocks of BBC is a top presenter
basically claims he paid a teenager for
explicit photographs tonight a lawyer
for the young person involved
sensationally denied the star did
anything wrong but why did he remain on
air for so long after the explosive
allegations were first made we'll have
all the latest
President Biden meets King Charles and
the Prime Minister after major
disagreements over support from Ukraine
and the use of cluster munition will
debate the state of a special
relationship
but she's the world's most canceled
comedian Roseanne Barr's Outburst even
got a drop from her own show tonight
fasten your seat belts Roseanne goes
uncensored
[Music]
live from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from New York and
welcome to Piers Morgan on Center
property at the BBC matters it matters
because every British person with a
television has to pay for the BBC
because it's a National Institution
millions of people trust it it
represents Britain across the world so
the public has every right to expect
that the people running it are fit to
bear that responsibility and once again
they appear to have let us down
this weekend a major BBC presenter was
pulled off air suspended and then
reported to police so the grave and
explosive claims that he played a
teenager for explicit sexual pictures
tonight a lawyer for the alleged victim
now age 20 sensationally rejected the
claims made by his mother to the Sun
newspaper as rubbish a letter to the BBC
says nothing inappropriate or unlawful
has taken place between our client and
the BBC personality the statement came
from a prestigious Law Firm the same one
which used to work with the late queen
that of course prompts other questions
the sun which uncovered these claims
says we have reported a story about two
very concerned parents who made a
complaint to the BBC about the behavior
of a presenter and the welfare of their
child their complaint was not acted upon
by the BBC we've seen evidence that
supports their concerns it's now for the
BBC to properly investigate well the
alleged victim's mother told the son he
started paying her child at the age of
17. payments soared to 35 000 pounds
it's alleged over three years fueling a
crack cocaine fiction in the young
person involved the mother didn't ask
the son for any money in her words all I
want is for this man to stop paying my
child the sexual pictures and stopping
funding my child's drug habit now there
are clearly many many unanswered
questions about these claims undoubtedly
there will be more claims made probably
as this show is even airing it's
claiming counterclaim with most of the
public none the wiser about what the
hell is going on but the BBC's response
is already becoming a scandal of his own
the family complained to the BBC on May
the 19th that's seven weeks ago they say
nobody called them to discuss it in any
more detail but in the meantime the
presenter stayed on our screens he
attended formal events as a BBC
personality according to the family he
even made another one thousand pound
payment in June the son smashed his
story on Friday night and the BBC didn't
seem to be able to tell even the BBC
what it was doing about it
yesterday we did have the announcement
that the unnamed presenter in question
has been suspended by the BBC the BBC
said in a statement the BBC first became
aware of a complaint in May
new allegations were put to us on
Thursday of a different nature and in
addition to our own inquiries we've also
been in touch with external authorities
in line with our protocols
so the BBC tells the BBC he can't verify
the claims about the BBC but the BBC is
investigating says the BBC to the BBC
and on and on it ran and of course they
all know exactly who the presenter is
that they're all talking about all
weekend other male BBC presenters who've
seen nothing to do with this story have
been wildly defamed and abused and
shamed online these include Gary Unica
Nikki Campbell Jeremy Vine Ryan Clark
all outed supposedly by idiot armchair
detectives as the presenter involved in
this Scandal and the BBC left from
hanging out to dry forcing them to issue
their own Furious and sometimes not so
Furious but just accepting denials
accepting because what else can they do
given how social media operates but
these unfounded claims are disgusting
and defamatory if I were one of those
BBC personalities who's been dragged
through the mud like this I'd be suing
the people on social media that do this
with impunity and those who make those
allegations need to realize that is
serious it's not a game you're actually
trashing people's entire reputations
just for the clicks and that's not
acceptable only yesterday did the BBC
finally confirm and suspended the
presenter and referred the allegations
to the police has met is now working to
establish if there is any evidence of a
criminal offense and says this thing
stand there is no formal investigation
of course this is the same BBC that flew
a helicopter over to Cliff Richard's
house after false allegations were made
against him the same BBC the Harvard
Jimmy Savile that woeful loathsome
predator for decades the same BBC and
the same director General Tim Davey
though who acted without hesitation to
suspend Gary lineke because he tweeted
something he didn't like about refugees
it seems a war sense of priorities here
and it's causing a lot of unrest amid
other BBC staff
it seems to be a failure wrapped up in a
fiasco inside of fast against the
backdrop of the scandal of Phillip
Schofield ITV which rocked British
television and the country frankly the
hesitation looks even more unforgivable
and whatever the truth about these
allegations and we do need to get to the
truth very quickly BBC leaders have
managed to put another nail in the
coffin of our trust in the BBC
well joining me now is the talk TV
presenter former culture secretary
Nadine Doris a former BBC News night
political editor Michael Crick I'm a
chairman of founder of intertalent
Rights group Jonathan Chalet so welcome
to all of you Michael Crick let me start
with you as a BBC man for so many years
what do you make of this obviously we
don't as things stand really know
exactly what has happened his claim and
counterclaim but we do know that a very
uh senior BBC presenter has been
suspended by the corporation and we do
know that apparently the first
allegations were made to the BBC about
his conduct back in May so what did we
make of this well I think tonight it
looks uh rather less serious for the BBC
than it did say 12 hours ago first of
all we've had the Metropolitan Police
today saying at this stage they're not
investigating which rather suggests that
they don't think the evidence that
they're aware of so far is strong enough
that they're much more important is this
uh statement by the lawyers for this
young man that uh the the sun story is a
load of rubbish
um and that he actually contacted the
sun to tell them that on Friday well I
mean you're a former tabloid editor what
was the editor of the Sun what was the
Sun newspaper doing going ahead and
defaming an unnamed member of the BBC
staff on the basis of an experience by a
young man that the young man denied I
mean it seems to me that all of this
attack all of your monologue just now is
all about attacking the BBC I think the
Sun newspaper the Murdoch Empire has a
lot to answer tonight and frankly one
has to wonder whether the articles that
the sun has been running over the last
few days are all part of that ongoing
war between uh Mr Murdoch and his
newspapers and the British Broadcasting
Corporation
I mean I think the the sun has been
pretty robust in this response it was a
pathetic that that was what happened
just to be clear I'm not I'm not
involved in the inner workings of the
sun on this I have no inside knowledge I
realize that but the evidence they had
all I've seen their statement
the mother of the alleged victim has
clearly been talking uh freely to the
sun apparently for no payment about all
this so clearly the truth is going to
want is going to emerge and like I say
we don't actually know as things stand
where that truth lies and the son of
course took a decision not to name the
presenter let me bring in Nadine Doris I
mean Nadine uh Michael quick raises some
interesting questions there but again
we're all slightly guessing aren't we
about what has really happened here but
is it is it right as many believe that
the BBC in the way they've handled this
once again seem to be lacking
so yeah again it seems like it doesn't
matter what crisis threatens to engulf
the BBC and there have been many over a
number of years they seem completely
unable to be on the front foot and to
have a a robust set of processes in
place to deal with complaints as they
happen past the BBC problem is that they
just don't seem to be able to deal with
issues as they arrive and one would have
thought the experience they've had
whether it's been with Frank bath or
Gary lineker or whether it's
um Jimmy Savile or whoever whichever
situation arises you'd think that by now
they've got enough experience with
dealing with the potential crisis to
know what to do how to do it how to how
to protect their own brand which is the
BBC and also how to make sure that they
deal with the complaints effectively
because you know at the back of all of
these complaints there are always real
lives and real people and real victims
and that's part of the tragedy if they
could just get on the front foot and
deal with things quickly and effectively
then a lot of hurt would be saved all
around and I think that's that's part of
the problem it's an inefficiency and uh
an inability to deal with what are very
serious problems you know you're quite
right in your opening comments the BBC
is paid for by the British public by
license fee payers and that's not a
cheap cost to people who are struggling
with cost of living at the moment the
BBC has a responsibility to the people
that it serves and sometimes it just
asks as apps as though the only people
the BBC have to satisfy are the BBC is
the BBC itself and it isn't it should be
accountable it should be transparent and
it has to answer to the public and
that's sometimes what it forgets and
what it always fails to do
Jonathan Charlotte there are lots of
reputations at stake here the BBC the
presenter concerned obviously the the
young alleged victim that victim's
family so many people uh indeed the the
media themselves of course as Michael
Crick said
um
what about the issue of social media
what about the way that so many
completely unconnected BBC presenters
have been dragged through the mud you
know I saw Nikki Campbell talking about
how distressing he found it Jeremy Vine
how distressing he found it uh Gary
lineker having to clarify it wasn't him
Rylan Clark and so on I mean it's been
appalling to watch but it reminds me
again that you know the the mainstream
media have a lot of restrictions on them
a lot of restrictions now uh some of the
most Draconian actually in in the Free
World but social media Remains the wild
west what do we do about this well the D
Ventures culture sector tries to do a
lot about that it's horrific what's
going on on social media not just this
matter continually so terrible things
are happening on social media and people
are being named I mean the reason most
people in Britain know the individual
presenter is it's because he's been
named on social media and to add to that
their pictures which are going around
social media whether they're real
pictures or AI pictures I don't know but
the picture looks a pretty unpleasant
picture the problem with social media is
you rightly said peers whether it be
talk TV the BBC ITV Channel 4 they're
very carefully governed but social media
is out of control and the government
until now in spite of all their efforts
have been unable to control social media
Michael Craig the presenter concerned we
all know who it is the public don't know
who it is yet would it be prudent for
this presenter to Simply come out if he
has nothing to hide if what this uh
young alleged victim has put in this
legal letter is true and there's nothing
illegal or improper about whatever
relationship they may or may not have
had would it not be uh the smart thing
to do for this presenter to come out and
talk frankly about this and and maybe
not even defend himself but just say
this is what happened and I have nothing
to hide I think uh that might it might
well make sense for them to do that
indeed I think uh managers in the BBC
there's some frustration there that this
presenter hasn't done that yet and that
they uh daily wish that they would do so
because I think at some point they're
going to have to come out and make a
statement about what did and what didn't
happen
um and I suspect it's it's uh somewhere
between uh I didn't do anything wrong
and uh the allegations that the the sun
has made
um but I I I don't think that they can
remain in hiding for uh forever they're
going to have to say something before
long and they might as well do it now
rather than wait a another few days or
maybe a few more weeks nice step in yes
and say all three of you have attacked
the BBC in different ways I think as has
happened today with this letter from a
top law firm is called harbottle and
Lewis I understand as you as you said
the law firm connected with the queen
they've sent a very firm letter saying
that the alleged victim is saying what
his parents have said weren't wasn't
true on that basis the BBC have been
wise to hold to hold back and not say
too much because the facts clearly
aren't known and I think it's wrong to
expect the BBC to jump in and give a
conclusion to this until they know I
also suspect they're presenter in
question has probably been told by the
BBC to say nothing I would put money on
that so I think there are no options but
to wait and also remember all weekend
there's massive allegations of 17 he was
17 when we started well the police have
jumped in today and they've made it
clear they're not rushing this so we
don't even know if the police agree it
was a 17 year old at the time so I think
quite simply as much as the public would
like to know more and as much as
everyone's pushing for the public to
know more the BBC has to be responsible
to also the alleged victim the presenter
the presenters family it's not simple to
say name and chain someone immediately
without all the facts being known that's
not to say or condone what did or didn't
happen but I think caution is the right
thing until all the facts no I don't I
don't disagree with that but it's been
it's been an awful mess the way that
other presenters have been Dragged In
from this uh and of course we don't know
what evidence the sun has they've been
pretty cautious so far in what they've
published they haven't revealed the name
of the people of the person they're
talking about they haven't revealed much
information at all about that so I think
we have to wait and see what the sun has
it been as I said robust in their
statement in response to this legal
letter and we'll see where this all
takes us uh Nadine actually I don't
think peers that they have been robust
in response to this legal letter they've
what they've done is they've gone back
on the attack against the BBC they
haven't actually specifically answered
the question that the points made in
this legal letter which are that this
young man has denied uh the the story uh
as total rubbish
um and also they haven't answered the
point made in the legal letter that the
young man contacted the son on Friday to
tell them that it was is rubbish what's
the son's response to that I think
actually it's a very weak response from
the Sun tonight what we're going to I
think we're going to find out I suspect
from the Sun exactly what they have
which is behind their decision to
publish in the first place and we'll see
what that is but you make perfectly
valid points and Nadine you've had to
deal at the sharp end in government of
what to do about social media uh what do
you make of what's happened in the last
few days with so many completely
innocent people getting their
reputations completely trashed
and I've spoken to one of those people
myself actually
um yeah it's it's incredibly difficult
it is the social media is like the wild
west and with the Online safety bill
which is being debated in the Lords at
the moment hopefully some of the
Amendments the Lords will put down to
what has been a watered-down bill since
the new admination Administration took
over will have some really robust
measures in to deal with some of this
but it's um it's always going to be that
balance between you know freedom of
speech the fact that we now have social
media something which is still a
relatively new and recent territory with
the new emerging platforms which are
constantly
um constantly coming up so it's always
going to be a battle and we're always
going to play catch up whatever the
Online safety Bill puts into law and
which hopefully will receive Royal Ferry
uh later this year will finish its
January Parliament by the summer once
that bill becomes law there were
Provisions in it which means that the
bill can continually not have to pay
catch up and will continually be able to
amend I'm not sure if those Powers will
still stand by the time we reach the
Autumn I hope they do because if they
don't we'll be in a position where a
bill becomes law in the Autumn which
will already be out of date by the time
that happens because there's platforms
AI all the problems that we're facing at
the moment as a result of internet usage
is moves so fast that it's very
difficult for governments to keep up
the dean Doris thank you very much
Michael Crick thank you very much
Jonathan Charlotte thank you very much
and we're told there are more
Revelations coming in the Sun newspaper
tonight so we will see what they have to
say and the story I'm sure was a long
way to go on since the next uh tonight
President Biden making Charles in
Windsor after spending only 47 minutes
with our prime minister which is soon at
will debate the state of that special
relationship is it still that special
with my pack live from New York City
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
live from New York City looking at the
Statue of Liberty glistening in the
lovely balmy late afternoon bit of
sunshine certainly very warm
um it's been pretty warm in England
President Biden arrived in the UK today
to talk to the British sunac on Ukraine
and of a big NATO meeting in Lithuania
tomorrow he was also treated to a royal
welcome by King Charles and the two held
climate change talks at Windsor Castle
the president's faced criticism since
the US announced they would provide
cluster bombs to Ukraine with the UK
Canada New Zealand and Spain all
opposing the use of such weapons last
year former White House Press Secretary
Jim basaki said that using cluster bombs
is a war crime
there are reports of illegal cluster
bombs and vacuum bombs being used by the
Russians is there a red line for how
much violence uh will be tolerated
against civilians in this manner that's
illegal and potentially a war crime it
is it would be I don't have any
confirmation of that we have seen the
reports uh if if that were true it would
potentially be a war crime
well joining me now is a former
conservative MP Louise mench former Navy
SEAL Rob O'Neill and talk to these
political editor Kate McCann okay I'll
start with you I just want to just
before we come off that story We LED on
uh the sun has now posted a new story
saying the parents of the youngster at
the center of this BBC presenter Scandal
have said tonight that they've spoken
out to protect their child they stood by
their allegation that the BBC star paid
their child thousands in return for six
photographs the mother and stepfather of
the youngster also questioned who would
paid to provide the child with an
expensive lawyer
um so the lengthy Story the son had just
posted which maybe will offer more
clarity on this tomorrow from a
political point of view okay the BBC
obviously the government always gets
involved in this lots of politicians
giving their views what is the current
feeling do you think from the government
about what's going on there with this
presenter
well I think the feeling overall across
politics is that this is a concerning
Story I mean the prime minister's
official spokesman was asked this
morning what Rishi sunak thinks of it
and he said that the allegations are
worrying and across the political
Spectrum there has been a consensus that
the BBC needs to ensure that its
processes are fit for purpose that it
has done everything it can to follow up
the complaint by this youngster's
parents the claim is that that was not
followed up accurately in a timely
manner that the parents were deeply
concerned that nothing was really
happening I think tonight the fact that
the BBC is reporting on this statement
from the youngster claiming that the
allegations have nothing to them has
caused some people to question what
really is going on here but as I'm sure
you have said and I'm sure many people
have said across the board the Sun
newspaper is very careful it has been
very diligent in ensuring that the
allegations have the weight that will be
required to publish them and I think
this Fair the article tonight further
enforces that there will there still be
those questions leveled at the BBC about
whether they have taken appropriate
action and those still remain
right well we'll see uh certainly a
fast-moving story and Kate the other big
news of course in the UK uh you've got
this NATO Summit coming uh from Tomorrow
you've had President Biden in the UK
meeting Richardson meeting King Charles
one of the main bones of contention here
is about the United States decision uh
through President Biden to send cluster
bombs for Ukraine to use against the
Russians who themselves have used
cluster bombs throughout this War uh
this is something to be the the UK
government implacably is opposed to how
much friction is that going to cause
with these meetings do you think
well the reality is that it did come up
in the meeting between the Prime
Minister and the president today but not
much friction is the answer to your
question because realistically although
the UK is as you say signed up to a
convention not to produce and to
discourage the use of cluster bombs when
the two men met in Downing streets
although the prime minister's official
spokesman did say that the issue was
raised I think it was very clear that
the Prime Minister did not really push
the president not to use those cluster
weapons in fact there was a further
statement made about how difficult the
position that the U.S finds itself in
regarding the production and providing
Ukraine with these weapons it really is
I mean President Biden himself has said
that he had to be convinced to send them
that he essentially didn't really want
to have to but that Ukraine is running
out of ammunition and that the US is in
a position to do so one that the UK of
course isn't and many other countries
who have signed up to that convention so
I don't think politically there's going
to be a huge amount of pushback on the
Americans but there will be talk at the
NATO Summit about a long-term commitment
to Ukraine and that will Encompass not
just ammunition although that will be at
the Forefront of lots of those
conversations but more politically too
about membership of NATO about what
happens next about reinforcing and
rebuilding the country because there are
still those questions about commitment
and I think this issue about ammunition
about who is prepared to send what and
perhaps a hardening of some countries
when it comes to what is provided is
worrying for the ukrainians and that's
something that you know lots of Nations
will want to see A Renewed commitment I
think at NATO that that all of these
countries will stand behind Ukraine
whatever happens and however long this
goes on for and yes in some cases
however unpalatable that may be right
Rob O'Neill I can't think of anyone
better to ask about this you know all
about Battlefield Munitions is it
morally right for America who have never
said they wouldn't use them but is it
morally right for them to use cluster
bombs
for the ukrainians to use against
Russians I don't think it's appropriate
right now to use cluster bombs in this
place just because they're not a precise
munition and they're designed to fight a
big infantry if we were offensively
engaged somewhere as the United States
as NATO and we needed to really push
someone out in our interest yes you can
use them but I think right here just
because of where it is they said it's
not a place where civilians aren't now
which is true but that's not the case
will they be there later and I just
don't like the idea of someone stepping
on one someone picking one up and have
you know they will clear it eventually I
just don't I don't I don't like the idea
of cluster bombs for those who don't
know what they are what is the issue
about cluster bomb well it's it's a bomb
that's dropped in an air burst out about
70 other little bomblets which are
smaller bombs with parachutes and then
they explode in the air and air burst
and they're designed to take out person
now the problem is a lot of them don't
go off and then you just got a mine a
shiny little toy sitting there on the
ground that and even if you know you
only need to be unlocked Unlucky One
time to step on one or if a kid sees one
in 10 years and 20 years which could
happen I just don't think it's the right
place right now because it's not an
offensive War I don't think this is a
defensive weapon at all Louise what's
your view of this because I mean a lot
of people are saying you've got to stick
it to the Russians with everything
they're sticking it to the ukrainians
with but if they're not a moral
compulsion to us to be above
and take the moral High Ground here I
don't think there's any kind and gentle
way to blow the enemy to bits and the
difference between Russia offensively
using cluster bombs and Ukrainian cities
where children can pick them up and
Ukraine deploying them on its own
territory that is the key Point here I
think the objectives would have a much
better point if we said go ahead Ukraine
use them in Russian cities Ukraine knows
how to protect its own civilians and
they're using them in fields where it's
not very built up and really who are we
to tell Ukraine how they can defend
themselves the biggest danger to
Ukrainian civilians including children
is the genocidal Russian army that is
parked right there in front of them and
the best thing we can do for Ukrainian
civilians is to get rid of the Russians
as soon as possible what about this
whole issue Rob of
Ukraine membership of NATO Putin will be
telling his people as he always has done
this is exactly why I had to take action
in Ukraine because this was always part
of the plan that they would become part
of NATO and that would be a existential
threat to our existence right on our
border
um of course you could argue that what
Russia has done in Ukraine is precisely
the reason why Ukraine should be a
member of NATO because if they had been
Russia probably wouldn't have gone in
because they'd know that then America
and the rest of NATO would have to
intervene right Vladimir Putin knows he
can say this is exactly what I was
trying to avoid because it makes him
look like he still has something to
stand on but president uh Biden said it
the right ways we can't do it now
because then that's potentially world
war three and NATO was formed to prevent
World War III not to start it and if you
can't I mean Vladimir zielinski is going
to the to villainous for the convention
and I mean everyone knows NATO's
involved with this now and my thing is
either get in or get out you don't need
cluster bombs B-52 if you want to get
them out of there we know we're doing it
we're Mission creeping it again we're
spending a lot of money in needlessly
wasting life as far as I'm concerned
what is does this end Louise this this
war in Ukraine do you think no I don't
think you could believe a word that
comes out of Vladimir Putin's mouth if
it was really about NATO he would have
done something when we put 800 miles of
NATO directly on his border when Finland
joined NATO what did he do he didn't lob
so much as a snowball over the fence
this only ends one way with Russia
leaving Ukraine it really is quite that
simple and that's the only way forward
now is Ukraine going to join it well of
course not because there's a war going
on in the middle of of we don't want to
go directly to war with Russia but we
are going to help them I think we need
to help them quicker faster we're
dragging this out I agree with Rob that
we should be giving them exactly what
they need including attack ons including
aircraft so that we can supply them with
the weapons they need to defend their
own country and just get the Russians
out there was a moment Rob was a bit
disconcerting as so many are with
President Biden where King Charles
appeared to be scolding a guard and
trying to direct the president seem to
be losing his way as to exactly where he
was or even what day it is
um I don't know if we've got any footage
of that but it was I think we've got it
we've got it here I think but it was all
a bit awkward and the president does
look like he doesn't really know where
he is this is the latest in a series of
well just embarrassing sort of senior
moments yes President Biden's fallen
over he's tripping on planes he's you
know said some Daft things and so on how
concerning is this to you as an American
citizen we've seen President Biden have
a lot of gaps on stage shaking hands
with invisible people in his defense on
this part I think when a lot of
Americans go over there they haven't
been briefed up or studied enough on how
to handle the royal family we've we've
seen it with President Trump we saw
President Obama give the queen an iPod
that didn't work I think we were talking
about the Green Room they make a they
make a point of
accidentally making themselves look like
that um you know don't walk in front of
the king even I know that but uh I think
the king did a good job kind of grabbing
president behind saying hey pal let's do
this well actually I was more concerned
with the president kept grabbing the
cane because you just don't touch the
Monarch I mean Louise we know this when
the Australian Prime Minister Paul
Keating once did this to the Queen
Elizabeth he was called the lizard of Oz
by the British papers because you do not
touch the Monarch and uh Biden kept
President Biden kept putting his arms
grappling like an octopus around our
Monarch trying to get a better sniffer I
think he was just being friendly and
afterwards uh the king spokesman said
look at the great warmth there is
between these two leaders it was a
flying visit he just wanted to give
reassuring signals about the special
relationship and I think mission
accomplished as far as that goes as for
his gaffes my favorite living President
George W bush you know was famous for
saying strategory and having a mouthful
of marbles so again I don't think this
is anything new quite I don't think he's
having a mouthful of marbles I think
it's has he lost his marbles might be
bigger concern for the world right now
uh Rob great to see you as always thank
you thank you very much indeed on
censored next she's the world's most
canceled comedian Roseanne Barr's words
have even got a drop from her own show
but she's back and I'll talk to her live
from my studio in New York City after
the break and she will most definitely
be uncensored
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
to Petersburg Grand Central live from
New York you're looking at Times Square
there on a pretty Pleasant afternoon
it's pretty hot and humid actually here
in Manhattan but fasten your seat belts
can be hot and humid right now my next
guest because it's someone who normally
has something very well worth listening
to
are you ever sorry we got married every
second of my life she's the world's most
canceled comic if you just feel like you
can't say it well the chances are
Roseanne Barr's probably already said it
I think [__] to you at all
and lately I've been getting her into a
whole lot of trouble
nobody died in the Holocaust either six
million Jews should die right now but it
never happens
the Jewish comic is accused of being
homophobic transphobic even anti-semitic
and was sensationally dropped from her
own sitcom for racist Twigs
fancy she's misunderstood critics say
she's missing her marbles I
threandaganti protects Me From Myself
Tonight I say she's uncensored
[Music]
I'm delighted to say I'm joined live
from Texas by the host of the Roseanne
Barr podcast it's Roseanne Roseanne how
are you
I'm great how are you pierce well I
can't think of anybody I would rather
have on a show called uncensored than
you
of course you're smart
have we gone mad Roseanne in our world
when I look at all the fallouts of the
things that you say or do
um I look at the sort of apoplexy that
people bring to jokes to humor to
sarcasm to irony all these things and I
I really despair the very essence of
Comedy for example is being expunged
from human life
yes it is uh yeah well you should
despair peers and so should anybody who
has a brain or um you know any Humanity
whatsoever or any connection to any
other human beings on Earth they should
despair to
um I say that they are weaponizing
stupidity and people have sunk to such a
level level that they can't handle
satire because satire is when you take
two disparate subjects and bring them
together to de-familiar defamiliarize
reality such as a poet does with words D
Familia defamiliarize
reality and they cannot hold two
disparate ideas in their head at the
same time because they're fed [__]
24 7 over the media and I'm about to go
crazy sitting here on the earphone
hearing the stuff you all are saying
about the Ukraine I'm about to have a
heart attack but I'm not even going to
go into it I'm from the Ukraine the
Ukrainian the Ukrainian there is a large
faction of Nazis I don't know if you
know this but there's a large amount of
Nazis in the Ukraine and they actually
killed my whole family I'm from the
Ukraine and they marched my entire
family grandmothers
10 siblings out into the forest and
buried them alive in the Ukraine so I
don't understand why everybody's Ukraine
you could well I do understand and
that's also what terrifies me people
better wake up and do some research on
their own instead of buying what comes
across on the screen and I tried to
shake them up pierce your goddamn right
I do I try to shake them up and crack
their their mind control programming I
do it for God
well here's resent what I would say to
that I don't agree with you uh about a
lot of the stuff you said about Ukraine
I know what you said you're perfectly
entitled to your views I would say in
relation to the suggestion that they're
all a bunch of numbers
is Jewish so obviously he is de facto
not a Nazi I know but he's not a good
one or or all Jews are the same for
God's sake talk about anti-semitic just
because the guy said you doesn't mean he
likes Jews or that he's doing anything
good for the Jews I mean so what who
cares what anybody is that was the whole
point of my tweet just because they're
just because they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk you know what I
mean just because they're the same color
as you don't mean they ain't trying to
lock your ass up wake up people
snap out of it
okay listen like I said you're
uncensored so you're perfectly entitled
to your views I'm entitled to a
different view I'm sure you would accept
that
it's okay you've got to be nice to get
your purpose you have a different view
peers I can speak respectfully to
another human being because I actually
you know I love to converse and I just
get passionate sometimes and I I love
that people disagree with me I love to
have conversations
yeah
it's okay I call Sebastian's fine there
was a a big outcry recently where I
defended you actually uh were you
recused of I know you didn't I watched
you I was shocked
right well you know I I call things as I
see them and on that occasion it was
clear to me that you were saying a
statement which you didn't actually mean
to be taken literally you were exposing
a wider picture yeah
yeah and the fact that it went over
everybody's head isn't my fault
well I'm going to play it let me play a
clip again to remind people of what got
you into trouble then I'll come and say
what I think about it be sure to be sure
to include the context which was there's
no way in hell Biden got 81 million
votes if you don't include that context
you're going to make me mad peers okay
well it'll make you mad but we've got a
14. we have a 42 second clip let's take
a look
the election was not rigged 36 counties
can give you 81 million votes right
that's a fact
so it wasn't rigged of course not yeah
36 Counties have 81 million people in
there see
that's the truth and don't you dare say
anything against it or you'll be off
YouTube Facebook Twitter and all the
other ones because we have you know
there's such a thing as the truth and
facts and we have to stick to it and um
you know it's scary
and that is the truth and nobody died in
the Holocaust either that's the truth
yeah it should happen if six million
Jews should die right now because they
cause all the problems in the world but
it never happens but it never happened
now I listen to that in full context I
listen to a lot more of it and it was
absolutely crystal clear and obvious to
me that you didn't mean anything that
you were saying that in fact you met
that you meant the complete opposite but
it was sliced and diced and put out on
social media and then the next thing is
you have you Roseanne Barr who is
actually Jewish being accused of denying
the Holocaust which obviously is
ridiculous why do these things happen
um because I'm I'm a targeted individual
as I say you know for 6 000 years there
has been a Jewish Civil War and nobody
knows about it and I speak about it a
lot but it's uh you know it's at its
climax right now and I have been
targeted by you know largely Jewish
people on the other side of the
political Spectrum our view is centered
on whether Israel should exist or not
and these are things we don't talk about
in public but when I ran for president
in 2012 they used to stand up and it was
always Jewish people with silver
ponytails marxists you know if it was
stand up I ran as a socialist and they
would set up and scream what about the
illegal occupation of blah blah and I I
couldn't believe it because they would
do it over and over and over again uh to
attack me because I'm a Jew I think but
Marxist Jews are not the same as the
kind of Jew I am and that's what really
makes me mad because when people assume
that there's only one kind of Jew
they're missing a shitload of history
and I feel like you know I'm here to
is speak to that and also the context
that I used was about the internet is
full of Holocaust denial Nazi comments
and saying but the thing they always say
is no Jews were killed in the Holocaust
but it should happen that's what they
all say and it's all over big shoot
comments YouTube It's wall-to-wall
that's why I left Facebook it made me so
sick it was wall-to-wall anti-Semitism
and um these same people these
socialists aging socialists which I
won't even go into what a scam socialism
is I've talked about that on online a
lot but anyway
um you know they they have made me their
Target because they don't think that I'm
the right kind of Jew and they don't
think that any Jew who thinks like I do
is the right kind of Jew and so I have
to live with that and it is within my
community and it's just like when black
uh people black activists come and talk
about you know being targeted by their
own Community too it's much the same
it's a cultural war and it is between uh
you know the uh far left and normal sane
human beings such as myself
well Roseanne I don't think any of us
are normal scene in human beings my
theory is we're all slightly nuts and
it's just a question of degree but
that's just a personal view uh we can
take a short break when we come back I'm
going to ask you the most contention
we're going to ask I'm going to ask you
the most controversial I'm going to ask
you the most controversial question in
the world
tell me the joke after the break we'll
be back in two seconds
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
assistant
coming up on the talk the young person
at the center of the BBC photo scandal
says nothing unlawful happened with one
of its stars but their parents are
standing by the claims judges are told
to get tough with Eco protesters and a
cervical cancer charity Sparks outrage
after calling the vagina a bonus hole
that's all at nine o'clock
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
live from New York who's one of the most
famous sites in the world of course and
still with me the world's most canceled
comedian which is still there Roseanne
Barr so Roseanne left viewers on a
cliffhanger you were about to tell me a
joke
yeah when I wanted to say two things one
is we have a joke those of us who have
mental health issues that there's insane
and out saying
so I wanted to cap off what you were
saying before but also I wanted to
finish saying that just last week these
leftists such as are in the Biden
Administration the state department of
the United States instituted a boycott
divest and sanction against the Jewish
people and in Israel
and also with American businesses who do
trading business with Israel so it's a
boycott of Israel and of America the
Biden Administration State Department so
there is never an end to uh their
censorship their Jack boot on on your
face if you don't do what they want and
uh if the Jews don't do what they want
but I'm happy to say that for the first
time in Israel and knesset
there is not one Progressive nor was is
there one leftist in the knesset and the
Jewish people in Israel couldn't be
happier and feel that they've been freed
from slavery
that's fine you said it what is the what
is the joke that you were going to tell
me
that the the met people with mental
health issues say there's insane and out
saying oh I see I'm sorry I'm sorry
thanks I thought you were making a
serious statement about it okay I get it
now listen Roseanne let me ask you the
most difficult question in the world
apparently what is a woman
how much do I weigh
no what is a woman
a woman is me
a woman is somebody whose breasts hang
down to her stomach and who has a
prolapsed uterus from giving birth to
five ungrateful little bastards who have
never had to work for a thing in their
goddamn life that's what a woman is
I see and how do the ungrateful little
bleeps uh how do they react when you say
things like this about them
oh they laugh they have good senses of
humor you should hear the horrible jokes
they tell about me
you wouldn't believe they have the worst
jokes about me because what's your life
grandson
I was going to ask you Roseanne you've
obviously been through the the mincer a
bit in recent years but how are you and
yourself I mean are you happy you have a
happy life
yes I do I have a joyous wonderful life
it's a bit hot down here but yeah I have
uh I own my
I own myself and my soul and my space
and my uh ethereal thinking and my art
and I have a wonderful loving family and
my mother's still alive she's 89. she's
a bit of a libtard but I overlook it but
uh and so are my gay brother and my gay
sister and all of my family actually are
libtards but you know I just pray for
them and love them
and do they do the same for you do you
think
oh they think I'm completely off them
they think I went off the the planet oh
yeah but they love me they just don't
they just don't engage but you know when
you're sitting there at Passover and you
know you're drinking the the cups of
wine to celebrate you know leaving Egypt
and what are your libtard uh nephews or
I mean grandsons whatever it is he
stands up what about the Egyptians who
were slaughtered shut the hell up
[Laughter]
you know here's the thing Roseanne is
that obviously you like saying you know
outrageous things and I like that about
you actually I think more people should
be doing this I love life um but but it
seems to me you don't necessarily fall
out with even your nearest and dearest
over it have we all just got two
sensitive are we too over offended
should we just be able to say outrageous
things and then have a drink and a laugh
with each other
check it out pierce the
The Swinging their penises and kids face
dress those are the people who say
shit's offensive
the [__] you know what I mean Jesus
hey hello
this is my advice to today's woman keep
your penis in your pants especially when
children are around women
Roseanne I think we certainly lived up
to the billing of uncensored uh thank
you very much indeed for joining me so I
appreciate it good to see you and good
luck with your tour which I know is
selling like hot cakes and I'm not
surprised that's it for me whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign